et en direct dans ce journal noémie ban
infirmières et président du collectif
inter urgence bonjour noémie merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
on vient de le voir l'union européenne
mobilise 220 millions d'euros pour le
transfert de patients entre pays lors de
la première vague le transfert des
patients entre le grand test et les pays
de la loire par exemple avait permis de
soulager les hôpitaux surchargés parce
qu'ils avaient des régions qui étaient
épargnées
cette fois l'ensemble de la français est
touché c'est donc à l'échelon européen
que le salut du conseil ne peut pas
venir
bonjour oui donc j'ai vu les
propositions de l'union européenne je ne
sais pas aujourd'hui nous y renonçons à
l'incapacité de pouvoir soigner tout le
monde parce que nous avons un manque de
lits les fermetures de lits qui continue
il faut le savoir les lits compte une
fermé et nous allons demander du coup
l'aide aux pays européens
ça me paraît ça me parait gros je me
demande dans quelle capacité ne pouvons
pas augmenter les lits en france et
devoir aller dans les pays européens
disons que déjà dans la première vague
en effet les patients devront tests
étaient transférés sur sur les
différentes régions françaises hip hop
psychologiquement pour les familles est
déjà très compliqué de voir leurs
proches partir loin d'eux aujourd'hui on
va les envoyer dans les pays européens
dits verts ça va être encore plus dur
psychologiquement pour les proches il y
aura la barrière de la langue pour avoir
des nouvelles
je m'interroge beaucoup sur cette mesure
là et dans quelles capacités nous
pourrons aider ces pays européens
on ne pourra pas donc à quel prix ça va
nous coûter d'envoyer nos patients dans
ces pays là l'europe qui me ferment donc
pas ses frontières pour l'instant comme
lors du premier confinement est ce
normal selon vous sachant que selon
marianne les étrangers
constituent la majorité constituant la
majorité des personnes hospitalisées
cet été en ile de france je comprends
pas bien le fait qu'on ne ferme pas les
les frontières en effet on nous demande
de rester à un kilomètre de chez nous
d'aller juste travaillé et aujourd'hui
on ferme pas les frontières
alors est-ce que économiquement il faut
ne pas fermer ses frontières là c'est
peut-être là toute la question
vous êtes infirmières quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui dans votre hôpital
bien dans mon hôpital la situation est
semblable à toutes les situations je
pense maintenant aujourd'hui en france
c'est à dire que oui nous avons beaucoup
de cas qu vide dans mon département il
ya beaucoup de soignants qui sont
atteints du cog hill sur ces derniers
jours ont fait face à une vague est bien
plus importante chez nous que la
première vague où on avait été très peu
touché aujourd'hui nous ait pas de son
toucher nos enseignants sont touchés et
c'est plus compliqué que la première
vague
vous êtes la présidente du collectif
inter urgence dans quel état d'esprit
elle personnel soignant face à cette
deuxième vague emmanuel macron a prédit
une deuxième vague plus forte que la
première
les personnels soignants reste un et est
épuisé dépité j'ai l'impression que les
soignants aujourd'hui sont complètement
dépité face à cette situation face à la
gestion de cette situation
face au manque de personnel de ligne les
nouveaux soignants les tout jeunes
soignants sortie de 2 des écoles il ya
un an deux ans ont déjà épuisé mes
collègues je le vois bien
c'est un goitre agit donc selon vous on
n'a pas pris la leçon du la première
vague
non on n'a pas pris la leçon aujourd'hui
c'est pire que la première vague
tout le monde est épuisé on arrive à
l'automne avec un nouveau confinement où
les gens sont déjà fatigués on est de
nouveau confiné et ça ça épuise savait
puiser troupes les troupes est la seule
solution c'était de pouvoir se
ressourcer auprès de sa famille
aujourd'hui ça c'est plus possible donc
gg je suis très inquiète sur l'avenir de
ces prochaines semaines
sachant qu'en octobre plon vendre enfin
la période automnale il ya un fort taux
de suicide je ne sais pas comment on va
s'en sortir dans deux trois mots en quoi
le ségur de la santé a pu vous aider
entre la première et la deuxième vague
eh bien c'est une bonne question
là les seuls effets comme on voit du
ségur de la santé et encore moi je ne
les ai pas encore vus parce que je n'ai
pas eu la paye
mais c'est au niveau salarial ou les 183
euros nous ont été accordés
malgré les 300 euros qu'on me demandait
c'est la seule chose que j'ai vu moi
personnellement dans les autres hôpitaux
c'est pareil on ne voit rien en fait il
ya juste être promet salariale de 183
euros mais qui est largement
insuffisante
il reprend le voit rien on sait qu'il ya
eu des infirmiers qui ont entre
guillemets quitter le navire récemment
en termes d'effectifs
comment est ce que le corps soignant
peut aborder cette deuxième vague
parlait beaucoup de manques d'effectifs
ont parlé dans le monde demain
d'effectifs est ce qui fait qu on ferme
des gi aujourd'hui aujourd'hui tous les
hôpitaux de france autant plans de blanc
donc on est obligé de revenir quand on
nous rappelle donc ça va être des heures
supplémentaires qu'on va faire alors
certes payé mais s'est épuisé à d'autant
plus le personnel déjà existants et ça
va ça va encore engendré des files de
l'hôpital public
aujourd'hui il faut donner les moyens de
pouvoir ramener les infirmiers les aides
soignants les médecins qui sont partis
de l'hôpital il faut que ce soit
attractive que l'hôpital soit attractif
qui est une gouvernance à ddd hôpitaux
avec les médecins et les paramédicaux
il faut redonner de l'attractivité
urgemment à nos hôpitaux publics merci
non libanais d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
infirmières et présidente du collectif
inter urgence